[Music]
hello and welcome to the dead stream my
name is Susie and I will be your host
this episode and I am joined this
afternoon by the fluff of nightmares
lady White Rabbit
hey guys I hope you're having a great
holiday season tonight by the third
voice of death mortis media everyone
this week always gives you a reason to
be afraid
unit 5 - to your listener their episode
6 of the dead stream
in this episode we'll be interviewing
units talking about Morton vampire
experience insidious Charles Manson and
much more we'll also be taking your
questions from the chat later in the
broadcast
super chats will definitely be addressed
so what have you guys been working on
this week or this month I should say and
what have you been up to this month of
course we've got Christmas coming up so
tomorrow I will be releasing my holiday
story that's exciting I actually just
listened recently to the collaboration
that you did with unit last year via the
Christmas yeah
that's got a spike in views like people
are starting to you know tune into it
again I guess it's because it's was last
year's Christmas specials oh right on
awesome yeah mark very good story I've
been doing longer videos to celebrate
the season stories around the fire and
stuff like that
and it's pretty much much of the same
loads of creepypastas lots of long big
creepy pastas I've been waiting a long
time to do are finally gonna be released
so it's usually divulge any of their
information yeah I mean I there's a few
I mean there was there's wand about
what's one that's about something that
lies underneath the Vatican I was there
a few weeks ago and I took some stock
footage just to play over it I thought
it'd be quite fun but I won't tell you
what it's about and I did a long
creepypasta about a year ago it's about
two and a half hours long featuring
loads of different narrators but this
time I'm gonna just re-release it with
just with just me because it's it was I
did it I didn't do it as well last time
it was a bit too blocky because I split
up into eight parts but I think it would
just be better as one standalone video
just read by me so that's something else
that's it's a really good really good
story to listen to so something
communit what are your plans well
there's not really much left for me to
do this year currently I'm working on a
sequel to a very popular video that was
on my channel called disturbing
videotape horror stories there's a
volume 2 and the works because the first
one did so well and I I felt like that
was a very unique topic it's not
something that a lot of hard channels
really have delved into when it comes to
ov it has always been something so
creepy about old videotapes and of
course me and Tim are also working on
bringing back the creepypasta universe
the same universe where Rick vs. dog man
took place The Burning Man took place
and various other stories so we're
bringing that connected universe back
onto the channel and I'm hoping that I
can get something for those of you who
aren't familiar Tim Tims on skis his
name right he is pasta writer and good
to hear that you're going back to some
of the creepypasta stuff that's always
something that I like to hear I do like
the true scary stories as well but I'm
I'm always down to hear both of those as
for me that's basically as for me I just
got over being sick for like three weeks
I think like if you listen to my last
two videos my voice just sounds super
weird so it's good I think like
yesterday was the first day that I
finally felt comfortable with my voice
back so it's good to have that back in
time for the dead stream I checked out
Star Wars the last Jedi last night did
any of you guys get a chance to see that
yeah I it wasn't my favorite I enjoyed
it I did have some issues with it but
you guys I would still recommend that
you see it for yourselves it's it better
than the prequel trilogy
okay I've actually liked the prequel
trilogy I'm know I'm probably gonna get
hate for that but what I like about the
prequel trilogy but would you consider
it like a notch above that in a way like
the I think the acting is better
and there are just some things that I
prefer about the new trilogy but what I
love about the prequel trilogy is it
goes and does something different and
the thing with these movies as that
they're kind of taking the formula of
the original trilogy and just doing them
again so I think I think they're give
some credits of the prequel trilogy for
trying to expand into new areas it
didn't always work but I appreciate it
yet the the prequel trilogy did have
some standout moments specifically with
Obi one the guy that they got the play
open was just fantastic
the the lightsaber battle in the Revenge
of the Sith is one of the best moments
in the series that was really good but
anyways we're gonna get into some
questions for unit so if you guys have
any questions in the chat we would love
to hear them but first of all I think
the question on everybody's mind is how
did you become our uncles how did that
all start well you know it's really
classified I really can't get into much
it would just be easier if everybody
were to just accept it as a
uncompromising fact like family gets
together as a kid and for some reason I
just can't remember you being there but
now that I've that have joined the army
I do remember you a triangle yeah I was
there he just didn't see me okay but uh
in all honesty I you I view the Hart
community as a family and I'm an uncle
in real life so it's just like uncle
unit you know why not so who are the
other like who's the aunt of [ __ ]
community who's the grandpa I have no I
I think there's actually a channel
called creeps creepy or something so I
guess I don't know I just know I'm the
uncle I'm hearing some congratulations
on your engagement in the chat and that
was one of our other questions thank you
for so you recently got engaged and on a
day on the day that you were going to
ask her you posted on Twitter and told
everybody that you were planning to
to propose to her so does does your
fiance not know about your Twitter
what's the deal with that she totally
knows about the Twitter but like I
wouldn't have posted it I would not have
posted that if I knew like she was gonna
see it she does like cheek she doesn't
have a Twitter personally and she really
she's more of a facebook girl so like
she she like has no interest in Twitter
whatsoever so I just decided to risk it
but I knew like for a fact that she
wasn't gonna say anything so should we
take
should we take she doesn't really she
doesn't really go on Twitter should we
take one from the chat um your plans for
Christmas and what do you plan it
are you planning any deadly seasons
Christmas horse or Show thing well I do
have a Christmas special planned which I
really don't want to get into I just
want to drop it on everybody so I'm
still working the details out on that
but I know it's going to be it's
definitely gonna be a creepypasta and
it's gonna be amazing and my plans for
Christmas is always chaotic for me
because I am a child of divorce and I
always have about three different
families I have to go to because I'm
with my fiance now so we have to go to
her parents I have to go to my mom I
have to see my dad so I'm always going
we always have to plan out days in
advance and particularly this year my
stepsister is actually getting married a
day before Christmas Eve on the 23rd
right yeah the 23rd like the Friday
before Christmas weekend and that just
that I really just complicate
complicates things even more so I'm
definitely not gonna be anywhere near my
computer but I'll have everything all
set up for Christmas and everything so
very good do you guys have any questions
for more unit
oh yeah
like you know there is a in the past you
had a couple of issues with some drama
online are you okay with all that now
oh yeah obviously I was looking at the
thing earlier and that was one of the
questions um where my thoughts on drama
and this community in general I I now
think it's it's really just unnecessary
and this is coming from somebody who has
initiated drama in the past and you know
I just looking back on all the things
I've been involved with I should have
just like let it go I really should have
just uh I shouldn't have been so
consumed with like jealousy and
resentment I guess and that really just
I got the bet they got the better of me
and I started things on this community
where that shouldn't have been you know
started and I I regret it it's not
something I can take back it's something
is like a black mark on my record people
are gonna remember that forever but it's
it really does take a backseat on all
the positivity that we have in this
community like and something that I've
I've had to learn the hard way and this
if any but if any narrators are
listening now it's it's um it's a good
piece of advice I think and the the
communication with other narrators is
less important than it is making good
content for your fan base and like you
know not everybody in this community is
really willing to work with other people
and you can't really expect that and
it's it's like it's a sad reality that
we can't all work together we all can't
be friends and stuff like that but when
you get a you get a group of humans
together on anything be an online
community or just like in general
there's gonna be problems people they
don't get along in general so yeah it's
just uh really just can focus on making
quality content for my fan base and
that's where I'm comfortable I don't
think I'm ever going to be involved in
any more drama because like I've been
involved in more than one
drama spa licks and I don't like it it
just stresses me out you know you get a
lot of hate over it and it's just
something that isn't necessary so I
definitely learn the hard way that I
shouldn't really dabble in drama
thank you much with all that being said
do you think that people are drawn
towards drama and that you can actually
use it to your advantage to help grow
your channel as we've seen some channels
do well in certain communities
I say yeah that's absolutely a
possibility but and this community in
particular there's I've observed a lot
of tribalism for back of lack of a
better word like the there's a core fan
base of the HAR community and it does
not matter if you disagree with a more
let's say a more popular narrator it
does not matter if you disagree with
them they are still at the end of the
day that person is gonna continue doing
what they're doing and they're not gonna
really experience any type of major
repercussions for it and you pointing it
out it's only gonna make people hate you
I think that's exclusive to this
community because I've tried to do it
before and I thought I was making a
really good point and it just turns out
that nobody really cares about your
personal preference yeah I think that
makes sense one of the things that we've
talked about before I think is that our
community is actually I think one of the
most supportive communities in terms of
people collaborating and helping each
other out and yeah giving each other
positive feedback yeah like I said
earlier there's definitely more positive
vibe in this community than other like
the vlog like I don't want to be
involved in that at all like the rice
gum thing and there's nothing like that
going on in this community I think the
biggest even the biggest drama thing
that has ever happened on this community
is nothing compared like that going on
but I don't think drama benefits hard
channels like it does like vlogger
or gamers or something you know I just
don't think it works that way on in this
specific community I think it's a it's
overall a bad thing because like we're
here to tell stories nobody cares about
what you think about this other person
who tells stories it's kind of like that
probably very few of us who are big
enough for for like a negative drama to
help us gain a following yeah like I and
it's just not it's not something that
has any really good positive benefits
and that's just my opinion no no I agree
and even if you were to grow your
following through drama once the drama
is over and everyone loses interest more
likely than not most of that following
will disappear with it yeah kind of like
channels that got big off of doing the
deep web thing and they try to dabble in
other territories when it comes to heart
and like they get no views so like I
don't want to be I don't want it I think
I had the reputation of being somebody
who starts drama and I think that's like
that's something I have to take because
of the mistakes I've made but really I
don't like being a part of drama and I
don't like being associated with any
type of like negativity towards somebody
else anything that I've said on Twitter
or something like that or like all that
so it's in the past you know it's it's
not something I even care about anymore
I do have one drama question for you
though what happened to the other five
hundred twenty one minutes well that's a
that's a very complex question you just
asked and I'll get into it though okay
so essentially there's two units there's
there's my fan base the unity and they
are the true units in my opinion but
there's also like other units that exist
in other dimensions that do missions and
they carry out various tasks and units
number one two and three are basically
the godhand of all the units they're the
voice of unit zero and nobody like only
them
only units 1 through 3 have contact with
unit 0 and units 4 through 10 are the
unites and the unites basically command
all the other lesser units so units 11
through 5 21 actually it goes up to 999
unit 999 is the last one so units 11
through 999 are the basic model units
that's what I am that's the particular
sect of unit that I'm from exist in
various dimensions like I said parallel
to this one and my mission here on earth
just happens to be telling stories on
YouTube so that is the best way I can
answer your question right mission the
we have the other 521 units and then
what about why do you think that there's
so many robots in the horror community
there's you there rain boss there's
marge but there's litterbots what's the
deal with that I wanted to know that for
a long time as well well I think um you
know I I think I would consider myself
more a cyborg than a robot and I think
mark ba actually identifies as a Android
so like but like the concept of
fictional characters like when it comes
to horror personas here on YouTube like
what like a robot why not you know I
mean it's just awesome so III I'm sorry
I don't have a better answer for you but
I guess like whoever when they were
thinking about making a persona online
they might may have been influenced by
movies like The Terminator or something
else like uh I think what whenever I
look at Malheur BOTS and rain BOTS I see
like I see a lot of inspiration from
like that the season the saga of Dragon
Ball Z where they were fighting the
androids and eventually it led up to
perfect sell I see a lot of influence
from there I'm not sure if they they
drew influence from that but I guess
like being influenced by just media in
general
so on the last dead stream right after
we finished recording it more you bolted
you had to go catch a train and you were
on your way to go see Dracula's castle
so tell us a little bit about that
yes well Dracula's castle was really
really cool really interesting I'll tell
you a few facts but I found quite cool
Dracula never actually went there he
never actually went to the castle that's
Dracula's castle that's that's quite art
man it's kind of like oh wait he never
actually went oh okay it was a cool
place to go to it's a nice place to
visit I mean if anyone ever gets the
chance to go I'd certainly recommend it
but although visually it is quite a
scary looking quite interesting it's on
the inside it's not very big
that is because the room it was owned by
the Romanian oil family and I think in
the 1950s it was given to the government
and then it was given back and when the
royal family got got it back the
government had taken everything inside
it and put it in museums so they got
this
hollow shell of a castle which obviously
had stipulated interest in you know the
worldwide community because of the
Dracula books and films that had been
out for years by them and then then they
just filled it with random stuff you
know I I did an Instagram tour you know
I put my Instagram story so people could
have a look what's inside but there
really just isn't much in there there's
the history of the castle and it was
just a war garrison which means it was
you know like a strategic fall so it's
very small on the inside there's not not
really much space but you know it's it's
just that's all it is it's just a small
pretty cool car I think I haven't seen
the originals you know but I I did tell
myself that I should definitely watch
some after after going
but if you when you get told or figure
out read the history about vlad the
impaler the guy who dracula is based off
it is really interesting because he did
you know impale people really really
horribly and the thing with impaling is
that you don't die straightaway you know
you want that stick for two days before
you bleed out or die from an infection
it's a really nasty way to go so he
quite rightly that name and dracula
means in romanian dracool is the devil
so Drac all became dracula and so forth
but yeah it's if anyone gets the chance
to go you know i i'd recommend it it's a
really cool place to visit but it's not
it's probably not the most impressive
castle in the world but still serious
because I've seen the Terence Fisher
Dracula and obviously Nosferatu and I
don't know if I doubt that those are
from the location or anything but they
always make those castles look so big oh
yeah no it's it is miniature I mean I
mean just to describe how small it is I
mean I can't even think about it it's
it's really like some rooms are like 2
meters by 2 meters you know it's it's
it's nothing you got you can walk around
the whole of it in about 5 minutes it's
tiny so in a couple of weeks we've got
the new insidious movie coming out any
early thoughts on that and have you guys
seen the other movies in the insidious
series I saw the first one and I
remember really liking it was quite a
long time ago though and then when I saw
the second one I think it had been too
long so I was kind of lost so I need to
go back and watch both of them again
before the third one was the fourth one
comes out or at 4th one see I'm a little
wine I've seen the first two and I I
really enjoyed those films I like the
direction they were going I think the
from what I've never seen the third one
but I take it they were setting up
something on
second insidious film where the lipstick
face demon from the first film would
return on the third film I'm not sure if
that's the direction they actually went
with but I thought it was a very
engaging story
I appreciate the connections made from
the between the two films that I have
seen it really just builds off I thought
it was a very worthy sequel obviously I
think the first strip that the first
film was a lot stronger than the second
one as far as the the overall energy of
the film it was a little bit more
claustrophobic in the first film but I
thought it was a very engaging story and
I thought it was a very well-made film
and the sequel followed up very nicely
and I like I said I have to I have to
view the third one but I probably would
see the third one very soon so I can go
to the theater and actually see the
fourth count even just in the third one
I think so it's insidious and the
country are they the same universe with
a different I think they're separate
universes I know an actor who plays one
of the I forget his name but his last
name is Ward one of the demonologists
from a conjuring is he actually played
and like both of the series oh ok ok
because I mean I got into it quite late
I didn't I didn't watch the first or
second in theaters and only when the
third one was coming out I was like huh
oh there's two more so my wife and I we
pinched watch one two and then we went
to see the third one the day after and I
mean I I really liked it I really liked
the continuation how everything cleverly
ties into each other and I think I just
be echoing what unit said but yeah I
just I really like the storytelling I
really liked how everything you like if
you were to watch it two years apart or
whatever or even if you don't if you
watch it like one day to the next you
can you know you can tell the little
different you can tell the things that
carried on and you know how they make
things linked up quite cleverly which i
think is good because obviously they
planned how they wanted the story as a
whole to be told maybe it's like a
trilogy
and then they just did part one two and
three so that it would have this nice
progression and everything would make
sense and be all very neat and organized
does a third does the third film involve
the family for the first two uh but
there are aspects that are carried over
by the by the lady the lady character
who what kind of a scene that goes third
one actually a prequel even though it's
called chapter three oh yeah yeah
alright they go back is also okay going
to take place before the first one oh
yeah I was I was gonna ask about that
because from the trailer it looks like I
mean I don't want to spoil it for anyone
but you know the state of some
characters is different I don't really
know like that it seems like timelines
are very messed up so I'm interested to
know like put together a timeline in the
video that I did on it last month and
basically the the spark notes of that
were that specks and Tucker are with the
lin shaye character in the trailer for
the fourth one so we know that it's
after the third one but we also know
that it's before the first one okay okay
I see I see I see I think there may
actually be segments that we see from
Lin Shay's past where she's a kid so it
could take place a little bit before the
third one and a little bit in between
the third and the first it might be
interesting to watch the whole crew a
lot interesting they decided after the
first one that the thread that ties them
all together was going to be at the lin
shaye character yeah everybody gives
them the opportunity to franchise it and
show like a bunch of her different
stories dealing with the paranormal yeah
I mean yeah maybe they were just
planning to see how well it did and then
if it did really well then they had all
these other stories to tell him and it
didn't it took off so they used on her
reaction of seeing the demon that looked
like Darth Maul from the first film I
got the sense that she kind of
encountered that thing before so I'm
just wondering if there's any truth to
that maybe I was that the the demon from
the first film the lipstick face demon
they got it kind of like Darth Maul
based on her reaction of seeing him in
the room I got I kind of got the sense
that she has encountered that thing
before so I'm just wondering if the
follow up films three and four would
probably shed light on if she or if that
was like a first time encounter but I
got the sense that she did she knew what
that thing was and like has encountered
and before I feel like they're gonna
save that for like the potential fifth
one because the second one's the
cliffhanger and then this will probably
take place before the first one and I
feel like she sees the the lipstick face
demon at the end because right there at
the end of the second one you hear that
same sound that yeah that thing makes so
like a like I'm and he was a terrifying
part of the first film so I'm I'm very
interested in seeing if the story is
gonna pick up where that left off if
they're just doing prequels you know
that's cool and everything but come on
let's answer the question that you left
off on the second chapter already well
at the end of the third one they
actually show her encountering the
lipstick face demon and that was kind of
like okay this is leading into the first
one now and they didn't explicitly stay
at this but my sense was that that was
like the first time that she met the
lipstick face thing okay so if she
encountered it in the in the third film
and saw it again in the first film since
the third film takes place before the
first of all it is like I guess my
prediction was correct that she she
actually knew about the lipstick face
demon prior to the first film right so
yeah that's interesting so moving on
from insidious we are coming up
on the end of the year and I thought it
would be fun to discuss some of our
favorite horror films or just horror
stories or topics of the year so I've
got my top five or films and I'm kind of
liberal with the the term horror films
for this because there's only so many
horror movies that come out in the air
so my number 5 I put Death Note and a
lot of people hated that movie and I
didn't love it but I thought it was I
thought it was okay
the Japanese Death Note movies were
definitely better but in a year where
there weren't a whole lot of horror
movies I put that at number five and
then I put the shape of water at number
four which again is more of like a
monster slash romance thing it was a
really weird movie did any of you guys
get a chance to say it no sadly yes like
the the cinematography and production
design is amazing and it's an
interesting story it's it's kind of out
there but very enjoyable and then the
top three I thought were really good
which were its mother and it comes at
night which I think was super underrated
it comes at night I hadn't heard of it
well you just said it just now it's like
a disease movie and it takes place after
a disease has wiped out what we assume
is pretty much the entire earth but this
family invites another family to come
live with them so that they can share
resources and it's just about like the
struggle of them trying to trust each
other it's a very small movie but I
think it was like the most suspenseful
and one of the best movies of the year
I'll have to check it out yeah but what
were some of your guys's favorites from
2017 well I'm gonna be honest I don't
actually think I saw five horror films
of 2017 which is a shame but I was away
for a while
not pure horror anyway but I think my
top three in number three was rings
which although was okay I suppose
because the ring franchise is my
favorite horror franchise I was I liked
it but I was a bit underwhelmed I just
thought it would be a bit better but I
just thought it was alright and of
course there was it I really really
liked it yeah I sort of had a stranger
feels stranger things vibe to me it was
very that's the kind of like feeling I
like it wasn't super scary but I feel
and it's the opposite in stranger things
has a little bit of an it vibe oh I
suppose I saw stranger things and then I
saw it original it takes place in the
50s and then the new one takes place in
the eighties yeah that's kind of why I
was I was feeling that but I think my
favorite film this year was was
Annabelle probably my favorite horror
film this year I really liked Annabelle
I never got to see that I really wanted
to see it I really leaders all you did
oh it's it's terrific well I think it's
a good film perhaps because I haven't
seen the reason anyone has been horrible
so I wanted to watch that first and I
wanted to like rewatch the whole
conjuring series before I got to that
but I wanted to see it while it was
still in theaters to support David F
Sandberg who of course it came from
YouTube Pony Smasher on YouTube but I
yeah he directed the short film lights
out and then they contacted him and
brought him out to Hollywood make the
feature nice oh well but the thing is
the way they've done Annabelle is
they've set up as a there's another
trilogy I thought it'd be you know when
the first one came out I thought it'd be
a standalone movie but there's gonna be
another one it's gonna be another one
hmm any any favorites from you guys
rabbit or unit
I'm gonna go ahead and stick with the
okay I got like top three plus a
potential so at three I'm gonna be
unoriginal and go with it again because
why not
number two have split I love split that
Becky met last day yeah it did the list
I was looking at so I think it was one
of those things where it can't it
technically came out last year but then
the wide release came in 2017 okay well
that's what I'm going with that's when I
saw it and then number one was get out
okay I'm not a fan of get out and I've
gotten a lot of flack for it and I would
honestly just consider more of a comedy
the yeah comedy there weren't really any
parts that were suspenseful tonight
there's definitely elements of it that
are comedic but I think overall it would
be probably considered like a thriller
or something mm-hmm like a psychological
thriller but I guess it's kind of hard
to talk about without spoiling it but
like about halfway through the movie I
was like I wouldn't it be funny if they
went in this direction and then like it
just seemed like a very Jordan Peele
comedy thing to do to go in this
direction and then as I was watching the
movie it was kind of like oh he really
is gonna do that that's not as funny god
it's actually happening Oh
everything you say quite tentatively
yeah it's definitely worth at least one
watch in fact it's uh that's on my list
get out but like I'll do five but I
gotta I gotta be honest there's a lot
that came out in 2016 that I did not get
around to seeing until like early 2017
my number five would be Blair which I
thought I was a big fan of the film that
came out in 1999 and I felt but this
this kind of was um a little bit of a
half-assed version of that film but it
still followed up very nicely and I was
very pleased with how the third act
wrapped up this film it's kind of like a
I kind of view it as a de facto remake
of the Blair Witch Project with higher
production value but I felt it was a
very engaging story there was a there
was some parts that kind of annoyed me a
little bit but overall I felt it was a
very decent number more I'm gonna go
with movie I'm not gonna lie overall I
hated it okay and I'm a huge fan of the
channel but the last 30 minutes were
really good and they were so satisfying
yeah that's what really makes that film
worth it to me Blair Witch it had a
again there was some sloppy parts in the
first two acts and I was kind of like
meh
but I I still I still thought it was an
interesting concept and then the the
final how they wrapped things up was
just beautiful and before you got number
four and after dark analysis comment
love to get out but I can see why it
wouldn't be everyone's cup of tea yeah I
get the reference number four is gonna
be it I really enjoyed it but I recently
I read the book and in its entirety
when it came out and I also watched the
like before its initial release I read
the book and rewatch the miniseries and
I think my problem with the remake of it
or the the new adaptation is I think an
important way to tell that story in
particular is actually jumping between
the timelines like the book does where
they go from the present which is in
like 1986 in the book and the pastor
which is like somewhere in the 1950s I
think drawing correlations between the
two timelines is a very very important
part to tell this story and focusing on
just the past it I get why they did it
and I understand like why they had to do
that but I felt it was lacking that
certain aspect of the story and at least
the miniseries made an attempt to go
back and forth between the timelines you
know I prefer the miniseries that the
first half at least the second half
which is awful but the
the miniseries I think is superior then
the film that came out but still great
cinematography great acting excellent
acting you know just a really good story
obviously I feel like it heavily homage
is the original story but it maintains
its its own originality at the same time
you know they're just they're kind of
like taking certain liberties with the
original story which you know I can
appreciate but it's it's definitely a
different experiencing that they are
going to go back and forth between the
past and the present in the next movie
just because I think they're planning on
doing it we're just one movies all the
kids stuff and one movies all the adult
stuff but seeing how popular those kids
have become in pop culture I think I
think they almost kind of have to go
that route and yeah and there's
definitely gonna be a few scenes for the
kid portions that they can now go back
and touch on yeah is it all kind of like
it all kind of seemed rushed a little
bit towards like the the second act of
that movie it was just kind of like
things are just happening back to back
and you know I just felt that there was
a lot of missed opportunity from like
scenes that I remember from the books
and everything but like there was a
scene that was not in the book that was
in the movie
involving the girl and the drain I'm not
gonna spoil anything but how they how
they did that scene where she was
looking down into the sink was just
beautiful in the movie it was just like
great cinematography all-around great
effects just like it was it was very
effective to me but a regardless of how
I feel about like if you compare the
adaptation to the source material
obviously they're all always gonna be
inconsistencies but what they came up
with was great number three get out I'm
not gonna go too much into that film
because like I said you have to you have
to see it it starts off kind of comedic
and it just like slowly you start to
notice things that aren't right you're
in there and it just builds up into like
this finale and it's just like it's it's
phenomenal number two going back into
2016 I would have to say don't bring I
loved everything I've ever seen that
yeah the the suspense Oh like not the
most original concept for telling a
story but the suspense how they built
the suspense in that movie had me on the
edge of my seat when I was watching it
me and my me and my girlfriend of the
things you know my fiancee but me and my
fiance were just like like what the [ __ ]
is gonna happen next
2016 was a great year for horror movies
yeah honorable mention I would have to
say the forest I think it got a bad rap
and obviously there were some problems
with the forest but overall I felt it
was a very solid film but number one
would have to be a movie that came out
in 2016 did not see it until 2017
obviously but the voice see the void
that was that was an incredible movie
that was just an absolutely incredible
movie like if you got anybody who's
watching this who hasn't seen a movie
called the void came out last year
definitely watch it it's definitely I
like it because it borrows a lot from
John Carpenter's The Thing also with
with its direction it reminds me of a
modern John Carpenter film it's just
absolutely amazing story and I like
science fiction horror and it just it's
a refreshing dose of theft right that
one done
could you give us the could could you
give us the cliff notes without spoiling
it just I wouldn't waste it
basically there's these people who are
trapped in a hospital and there's this
cult outside the hospital that is
preventing them from leaving and in the
hospital strange things start to happen
I don't want to give away too much but
these these creatures start to appear
and it all ties into a conspiracy with
the head doctor there that's all it's
all I can really say about spoiling too
much but definitely definitely have to
watch that film if you haven't seen it
it sounds good leave yours we'll have
some new movies that they can check out
and faced off of some of our favorites
from the air I can't believe we're
already 40 minutes into this but let's
jump into the news there wasn't a whole
lot of news coming out of the horror
community in the last month but I think
something that affected all of us is
the repeal of net neutrality in the US
so was it that's two days ago they the
FCC voted out net neutrality and that's
why we we themed this dead stream around
horror community on life support because
now with the the ad pocalypse 2.0 and
whatever is going to happen with the
loss of net neutrality i think that a
lot of creators are going to be in
trouble yeah I mean when it comes to the
Federal Communications Commission all
the members of that board have a hand up
their backside and that is the hand of
corporate influence it's just so blatant
that I cannot believe that this is like
actually a thing and they actually we we
I can see like everybody can see what
you're doing this is this has profits
written all over it you just it puts the
corporation's in a position to squeeze
us and squeeze companies like a Netflix
Hulu and all them just for higher profit
margins and that this is basically all
it is and they're really gonna [ __ ] a
lot of things over that but I feel like
the backlash so far as loud enough to
where they can't if they were to do that
and which they will but they'll probably
you know go at a slower pace and they
plan because of the splat and backlash
but there's going to be a lot of
negative publicity over a specific
company maybe Comcast's or another major
internet provider if the consumers start
realizing that certain other websites
are slower and stuff like that the
repercussions become reality that we
speculate on now I think that there's
gonna thing because people are saying
now like oh it's been two days and
nothing has happened yet so what's the
big deal but like they they know not to
do it oh yeah it's not gonna happen
right away slowly like break us down
over the next 10 years and start just
slowly adding in fees and slowing down
websites and censoring stuff
which is really a lot scarier than them
just you know something like that would
have an immediate public outcry yeah and
I think when it when it does happen the
public outcry will cause another
decision to be put forth to the FCC and
if they can't if they can't reverse it I
think if the outcry is loud enough
Congress would crush it that that's what
I think I meant like but the croix has
to be loud enough for that I think now
is really like our only chance to save
it because if they if they do one small
thing there's not going to be a huge
public outcry and if they continue to
nickel and dime us for several years
then we're gonna be a lot in a lot of
trouble
yeah like I don't I I gotta be honest
with you as an American citizen I do not
have much faith in our Congress as it
stands now and without getting too
political but if they have an iota of
integrity they will stop this from
happening they really need represents
supposedly represent the people like
they are gonna be held liable and the
most likely voted out if they're unable
to fix this whereas the FCC is just
appointed and oh yeah and like a
corporate power is control the FCC and
it's so blatantly obvious and it's just
like a I don't understand like they're
so brazen about it you know no man it's
just like they're wearing it on there so
yeah we're we're corporate owned and
we're gonna go ahead and go with this
decision and it's just like no like
obviously you're in this for profits and
it's just so like you and your master
rating it as like Internet freedom it's
it's definitely not that and we can all
see it anybody with a brain cell can
figure out what you guys are doing I
know supposedly 83% of people are in
support of net neutrality which that
alone is like an overwhelming amount of
people in support of this in still year
repealing it but really I think that 83%
is really more like 99.9 percent and the
the 17% who who said that they weren't
for it were just tricked by the fact
that they call it the restoring Internet
freedom
yeah I mean people are saying the
Chinese just like the opposite of
freedom what they're doing it's
completely deceptive exactly so yeah
have you guys been affected by the ad
pocalypse recently and possibly by the
return of net neutrality already well
the ad pocalypse hasn't really affected
me as lately when it first started the
the first time this happened it killed
almost ads on all my like almost all my
videos did not have ads because it just
all got hit at once and I had to file
repeals and everything and when they
they put out the update a while back
where they said that they tweaked the
engine a little bit a lot of the videos
that had yet to be reviewed got put back
in a good standing where it stands right
now is I I work my schedule around like
okay so the the video is gonna be
uploaded but I'm not gonna publish it at
least until about 48 hours later because
we're gonna have to go through because
it's automatically demonetised
automatically and I've gotten to the
point where I have to calculate that
into my schedule you know just like I
know it's going to be demonetised I'm
just gonna file for repeal and they'll
put it back in good standing and then
I'll publish the video and that's
basically how it's affected me but as
far as revenue return it's it's
basically like ever since the first ad
pocalypse has been down significantly
but it's it's not like I can't really
complain on what I am affected you as
much not as much but it brought on a
some rudimentary level probably but not
enough to cause a public outcry thing
for me I was a lot smaller when the
first one happened so in a way it kind
of helped me because people in the
community were giving up and just
stopped uploading so I was kind of able
to get more exposure like that but this
new one has like really really hit me
hard we're talking a little bit earlier
about rabbit you are not full-time on
YouTube so you might actually
we like being the best place here seeing
people give up again yeah I definitely
have a have a full-time job because I've
never made enough on YouTube to make it
my job so have you noticed more exposure
from this new ad pocalypse and like do
you think that you have a better chance
of just keeping your content consistent
no matter what happens oh yeah I haven't
really been affected by I was affected
once by the original ad pocalypse but
after a few reviews my my videos got put
back so I never actually was really
affected by it it's hard for me to tell
because taking sense from sense is not
noticeable so I put out videos because I
like to do it not because I'm making
money off of it and I don't see myself
going anywhere anytime soon I saw some
people and I started using the community
tab a little bit and they were worried
about with the loss of net neutrality
they were worried that they wouldn't be
able to watch my videos or I wouldn't be
making videos that's definitely not at
all true I'm gonna keep making videos no
matter what but if like most likely what
I'll have to do is is pick up another
job and it's just going to get a lot
harder and hopefully I can maintain the
same quality of videos yeah like 2017 I
think was a very dark year for YouTube
in general with the whole ad pocalypse
thing and now this it's just like 20
2016 was a very good year but like it
just like polar opposite this year for
YouTube we got a super chat donation
from Carrie temporary big thank you to
Carrie she's here like every single
month when we do the dead stream she's
always one of the first commenters
really means a lot to have that
continued support from you Carrie so
thank you so much thanks so speaking of
net neutrality and ad pocalypse is I
released the the new merch store finally
so if you want to support the channel
and pick
blue seas world merch we've got t-shirts
mugs handbags lineup of products yeah we
got Suzy's world tote bag oh that's cool
did you ever print that uh keep some
cream I'm sure I keep YouTube creepy
shirt and you can actually see it right
here in the banner but it's not
available yet so what that is is we want
to support the idea of continued horror
topics on YouTube and not getting kicked
off by the more added friendly channels
or the more kid-friendly channels so
what that shirts gonna be is it's gonna
each of those letters is going to
contain one of the one of the big voices
in the youtube horror community and the
only reason that I haven't released it
yet is because I need one more person to
fill in that P on the top right and I
want to make sure to get the perfect
channel in there but that'll be around
the corner soon and that that's one that
features me rabbit Mort and unit and a
bunch of other of your favorites and I'm
definitely gonna get that when it comes
out why so just a couple of other news
items and this isn't so much a youtube
horror story but Charles Manson died
over one was that about two weeks ago
three weeks ago hmm
and I noticed that Charles Manson and
other serial killers have kind of like
their own fangirls and this weird fan
base and people are saying that like his
death kind of commanded a similar level
of respect to Wes Craven
which is kind of messed up if you think
about it because Wes Craven actually
contributed awesome things and movies to
our society so like what are your
thoughts on like people becoming fans of
serial killers it's ridiculous they
would they wouldn't be fans if they
killed a member and family
with a whoa you killed my dad thank you
so much
I'm a huge fan it's ridiculous you know
oh it's just really I think people just
I don't know they get obsessed with you
know I like I just like follow it
through oh yeah it's so great it really
is baffling and something similar is a
serial killer his name his nickname was
the Night Stalker he actually got
married in prison to a woman and it's
like I don't mean to be misogynist here
but it seems to be like women some women
are attracted to just like these
monsters and it's just like it's
baffling because like you realize like
this person we if you were alone with us
but he'd probably kill you
and it's just like I don't know I really
don't see where this morbid fascination
comes from like the the topic of serial
killers in general is interesting on a
like kind of psyched psychological scale
but like I would not like dedicate
myself enough to where like I would be
like kind of like that guy who went and
visited Gacy while in prison like months
before he was executed like that guy
ended up shooting himself in the head
like if you go too deep into the serial
killer rabbit hole it's not good I think
general I like it when it's done
ironically when they're supported
ironically yeah but it really does seem
like they're people who like genuinely
are in love with these serial killers
which is really weird yeah I mean it's
it's but like these women are willing to
let you marry them and I don't know it's
it's very bizarre to me it's something
about like oh actually liked it like
here an actual psychologist dissect that
type of morbid attraction you know what
where does it stem from because it is
it's something that just completely
baffles me it's just like I also kind of
want to be careful because I feel like
some of the people who do feel that way
are also probably some of the people who
watch our channels
but maybe but like it crossed Charles
Manson Charles Manson I remember reading
an article about him obviously before he
died and he had this uh like this 25
year old girlfriend or something and she
looked she she wasn't like the most
attractive woman around but she wasn't
ugly and I was so curious that I
actually watched interviews with her and
is just like she just seemed like a
complete airhead and she claimed that
she didn't even know Charles Manson
murdered people like like coordinated
murders back in like the 60s I'm like
come on like well no I like you
absolutely nothing wrong with being
fascinated by serial killers and wanting
to dissect their mind and understand
like how they take yeah like I said it's
an interesting contouring topic speaking
strictly in psychological science terms
but like if if you're to the point where
you like actually won't like meet up
with these people in jail and stuff like
that I don't think that's ever a good
range that's pretty much it there wasn't
a whole lot of news I do want to before
we wrap things up answer a couple of
questions so if you guys have questions
right now great time to leave them in
the chat one of the ones that I noticed
earlier was somebody asked our
creepypasta is dying what do you guys
think about that I don't think so I
think they're still going pretty strong
at least in my case and I mean a lot of
the videos that I'd like to shoot into
are creepy bastards anyway but what
about you unit I think when people say
that they're obviously referring to like
the view count is not as not as
prevalent as like something like story
collections but I think the conventional
way of telling creepypastas is as not
getting the views I think that's what
they mean by that but if you can tell a
good story
like for example Clancy pasta my I'm a
big fan of his work he if you can tell a
story in a certain way it really doesn't
matter if it's a creepypasta or
if you're good at doing it you'll get
the views like I said when it comes to
creepypasta been around for a long time
and I think everybody has heard the
classics like Jeff the killer there's a
few of it like autopilot and stuff like
that if you're getting into creepypasta
and you're doing what's been done years
ago you're not gonna you're not going to
be successful at it because it's been
done before the fad is over the the hype
it's definitely not its peak at the
moment but like I said not to sound
conceited or anything I just think
creepy pastas like rake versus dog man
when you have like a very in-depth story
with interesting characters and a very
engaging storyline I think it really
doesn't matter if it's a creepypasta
no-sleep true scary stories when you
have those elements I don't do well I
think the thing that people are not
taking into account about like the whole
not controversy but the whole
competition between true scary stories
and trivia pasta is that 99% of the true
scary stories you hear are actually
creepypasta that are sound like maybe
they're true yeah yeah cuz I am my
channel I do I do no sleep collections
like I and I maybe it's my little
malicious for me to title them like I do
but you're getting exactly what's in the
title like two very creepy hitchhiker
horror stories no sleep I make sure I
put no sleep there because like these
aren't true these are not true they're
just too creepy
it's like horror stories they're from no
sleep that's right there in the title so
no no we're in the title is it ever
masker right is being true I mean I've
kind of I've kind of done it with
all-day intake creepypasta where most of
them I write them as like real things
that could have happened but they're
they're all fictional some people you
know some people think that they're true
anyways but I always I always brand them
as creepypastas yeah I always say like
these these stories are from no sleep it
doesn't they're not masses like these
aren't necessarily true there have been
true stories or no sleep but the
majority of them are creepy
and but you know the reception of these
videos have been mostly positive
you know people seem to enjoy them and
like Chris no-sleep is a particular
strand of creepypasta so I would say
like you know the concept of
creepypastas being fictional horror
stories they people still find them
interesting maybe the term creepypasta
has gone out of style a little bit but I
feel like the concept itself is
generalize well like my biggest series
in terms of views has been the things
you missed but if you look at the watch
time the amount of time that people
actually spend listening to it the all
the intake creepypasta is actually like
the highest watched series which is
pretty crazy because the other series
has way way more views yeah rather
you've been expanding
you've been mostly doing creepypasta and
kind of expanding into documentary stuff
I don't know if you're still planning on
doing that but what are your thoughts on
like creepypasta obviously scary stories
are going to be around forever but
creepypasta as a term yeah I definitely
think a unit touched on it that it's on
a huge downslope since I don't know
three years ago or four years ago and it
became suddenly a really interesting
thing and since getting any attention
I've had an endless amount of requests
to start doing more true stories which I
don't like doing so I don't but whenever
I do it's you know to appease those
requests and I get a bump of views and
clearly there's also a rise of true
stories right now which might dip over
the years as well it's just a trend
there's a trend going on right now which
uh I don't know I just the the
documentary thing is just because that
that fascinates me anyway and if I can
come up with a good topic that people
might find interesting
I'll I'll research it so do you talk
like you'll kind of randoms your
creepypastas as true scary stories if
the opportunity is there
yeah a creepypasta to me will always be
a fictional story and I've always been
okay with calling it that I've had
people email me stories that they claim
are true but it's written from the other
genders point of view that they claim
they wrote and I'm like it's so
obviously not a true story man I'm not
gonna lie to my audience they claim it's
a true story but they may remember like
the most accurate details that you would
never remember like oh yeah is yeah it's
one of the Disney ones the not abandoned
by Disney the Disney catacombs and like
one of the main facets of the story is
that like they they were put into this
room and they saw the room number was
like this the Serve number and then it
turns out that was the same that the
room number was like Disney's date of
birth but it's like why would you why
would you look at that and remember that
exact number and then go back and look
it up yeah it seems like people are
trying to brand things as true just so
they can get the views and that's not
right to me I've actually been trying to
branch out into other like a horror
related content because like you can
only do so many stories before you get
burnt out on it and I'm kind of I'm kind
of there you know like I'm never gonna
stop telling stories because that's what
I'm known for it I understand that but
like I want to get into like independent
filming and just maybe doing a little
bit like horror themed comedy at some
point so I'm definitely brainstorming
but I feel like I get pigeonholed I
never wanted to be pigeonholed as the
true scary story guy like and it's hard
not to be pigeonholed when your primary
content is that so like I'll never
transform my channel completely but I do
want to do other horror related content
so I can just like avoid this whole
thing in general for a little bit yeah
because then when you start doing
something else you're already like oh
what's this you got to be careful how
you approach new content because but you
have to I the way I see it as long as
you're delivering horror I think
if it doesn't go over well now people
will start to appreciate it more as time
goes on all right one more question that
Kari is asking did I write the story
that I did in units channel so I filled
in for units about a month ago and
narrated a story called fishhook I did
not write that one so who did write that
one unit that was actually TIMSS on skis
friend collaborated with him on telling
a true scary story like the apparently
the guy was not much of a writer so him
and Tim kind of got together and he
wrote that's why the writing is so well
on that story is because he wrote it
himself you know but he it's based off
that encounter from his friend I don't
know who the person is in general but
it's definitely the work of Tim sonski
but he he was uh it was listening to the
experience that his friend had and I
really do appreciate you actually
filling in for him because I was I was
doing with some personal stuff and then
right after that I got sick as hell so I
had he's always on my phone or community
gets sick at the same time yeah so like
I had to get CC to fill in for me I'm
like okay I'm ready to oh man my nose is
running and then the next day I'm like
oh I can't do anything check that out
it's called fish hook on units channel
I'm very proud of how that one came out
oh yeah it was very good very very good
production I'm very pleased with it like
and cz made like eat on the production
side he took care of everything and I
really do appreciate that ladies and
gentlemen it's seen it has come but
don't worry because we're gonna be doing
new dead streams every month the next
stream will be January 20th at 2 p.m.
Pacific that's 5 p.m. Eastern and 10
p.m. GMT
if you missed us live you can catch the
dead stream on-demand here on cz will
see Z's world for the full experience
where you'll be able to see the
real-time chat and whatever other images
we feel like showing you you can also
catch some recent episodes on iTunes and
your group or any news about YouTube
horror send an email to see Z's world at
gmail.com and let us know who you'd like
to see as a future guest the music in
the dead stream is composed by OST maker
visit his link in the description I go
ahead and subscribe to OST makers
channel for some more work and she will
find you on social media you can find me
on Facebook and Twitter just googling
lady white rabbits how can the fans
connect with you if you go at mortis
video you'll find me on Twitter and
Instagram unit where can our fans go to
check you out
[Music]
youtube.com forward slash unit 5 t2 and
you can find me on Twitter at unit 525
away on Facebook Google+ and Instagram
as sees world and my twitter handle is
CC spoiled hunters for horror if you
guys want to go check out that merch
just go to my website it's easy as
WorldCom and look for the merch store
unit thanks you for coming on the show
today and we will grab my remember to
subscribe to seize these worlds for new
Horrors every week
ring the DEATH BATTLE for notifications
and we'll see you in the next one
assuming we both survive
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you